the Department of Homeland Security
rejects new claims from a whistleblower
who says that he faced retaliation for
refusing to change intelligence reports
that did not fit president Trump's
political objectives he says he was told
to leave out details about Russian
election interference and the threat
from white supremacist Jeff pagay has
that
story in the complaint Brian Murphy who
oversaw the DHS Intelligence Division
until last month alleges that acting DHS
secretary Chad wolf and his second in
command Ken Cinelli ordered intelligence
assessments on Russian interference
efforts in the presidential election be
changed because they made the president
look bad Murphy says instead he was told
to focus on the interference activities
by China and Iran and he says that wolf
told him that these instructions came
from White House National Security
adviser Robert O'Brien is totally false
and I don't think there's anyone who's
been tougher on Russia in this
Administration than I have been and is
violence intensified in cities across
the country this summer Murphy says he
was told to modify Intelligence on White
supremacists in a manner that made the
threat appear less severe as well as
include information on the prominence of
violent left-wing groups and antifa in
line with the president's public
comments antifa is a criminal
organization Mark Zade is Murphy's
attorney information pertaining to
Russia and the analysis in the
intelligence reports was downplayed in
order to ensure
additional favorable information to
president Trump which was something Mr
Murphy said no he would not do the White
House denies that O'Brien ever dictated
such changes meanwhile on Capitol Hill
House intelligence chairman Adam Schiff
wants Murphy to testify before his
committee later on this month Murphy's
attorney says that his client will
cooperate with any Congressional
investigations Tony Jeff thank you very
much